-Our next guest
is an Emmy-winning journalist
who hosts "This Week
with George Stephanopoulos"
Sunday mornings and co-anchors
"Good Morning America"
weekdays on ABC.
Please welcome back to the show
George Stephanopoulos.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show.
-Good to be back.
-You have a congratulations
in order.
You just celebrated
a 20th wedding anniversary
with Ali Wentworth.
-Yes.
I'm very lucky.
-Fantastic comedian, writer.
-Did you you do anything special
for your 20th?
-We actually didn't, no.
[ Laughter ]
It was one of those things
where we both had to go visit
our parents that weekend.
-Oh, that's very nice.
-Yeah, it was just something
that had to happen,
but we had
a little celebration at home.
And we -- you know --
I don't know
how long you've been married.
-I don't know, either.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, everybody tells you,
"Oh, you're gonna blink,
and it's gonna go by."
-Yeah.
-It's so true.
I cannot believe
we've been together 20 years,
but it's been the happiest
20 years of my life.
-Well, congratulations on that.
[ Applause ]
I have a lot of questions
for you about your work,
but I want to start asking,
what time does your day start
hosting a morning show
the way you do?
-I get up at 2:30.
-2:30 in the morning.
-So this is nighttime for me.
-Yeah.
So you could
set your alarm a little earlier
and watch this when it airs.
-Exactly.
-So 2:30 in the morning,
you get up.
and is that
just for the purposes --
-It's the way my body works.
You know, I get up, I meditate.
And, you know, 7:00 a.m. --
We start to do some stuff
at 6:00.
7:00 a.m. has to be
the middle of my day.
-Sure. It can't be like
I'm rolling out of bed, so...
-So how often can you
actually go out
and do something in the evening?
-Almost never.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So for your 20th anniversary,
you had a brunch.
[ Laughter ]
You had a romantic brunch.
-Early-bird special.
-I want to ask you about
a recent interview you did that
received a lot of attention.
You interviewed Alec Baldwin.
You were the first person
to interview him on camera.
I can only imagine
how stressful it must be
to talk to someone
who has gone through
the traumatic experience
that he just went through.
-It was crazy, you know.
I've probably done, like you,
thousands of interviews
over the last 20 years.
I had never had
an experience this intense.
He walked in by himself.
The entire crew went silent.
And for the next hour,
it was just minute by minute,
gripping emotion from him.
And it's all so close
to the surface.
I mean, he's described it as
a one-in-a-trillion accident.
It was
a one-in-a-trillion accident,
but he was holding the gun,
and his cinematographer is dead.
"How do you live with that?"
is something --
You know, that was
the big question I had for him.
And it was so clear that this
was all so close to the surface.
I think he probably wasn't
sitting down in the chair
for a minute and a half before
he started getting emotional.
And the entire hour
was like that.
But to his credit,
he answered every question,
went through the entire day
with what happened.
The investigation
is still going on.
I think he just wanted
to come out and to say
his side of the story
and say how badly he felt.
-It's very wonderful
when you can provide
this sort of storytelling
of the things
that everybody
is thinking about.
And you're doing that, as well,
not just with that interview,
which I think everybody wanted
to hear what Alec had to say.
You have a couple of shows
on Hulu right now.
One is about Christopher Steele.
And obviously much has been
written about his dossier.
How are we to take
Christopher Steele right now,
based on the fact that obviously
there was a very partisan split
as far as how
he was evaluated at first,
and now where -- how would you
hold him as a journalist?
-That's a great question.
And we talked it through
with my team for hours and hours
both before and after
the interview.
I think, you look at
the broad outlines,
he was basically writing about
Russian contacts with Trump
and the Trump campaign in 2016.
Robert Mueller, you know,
sort of verified most of that.
On the other hand,
there were some other things
in the dossier,
like the famous pee tape,
like the idea
that Michael Cohen,
who was Trump's lawyer,
went to Prague to work out
some deal with the Russians,
that there is zero evidence
that has come forward
to back that up.
And, in fact, Mueller even said
that he, more or less,
could disprove
the Michael Cohen stuff.
So he was wrong on the most
sensational things,
or hasn't been able to verify
the most sensational things.
But in the broad outline,
this stuff did happen.
There were contacts
between Russia
and the Trump campaign in 2016.
And I think that gets lost
in some of the coverage
of Christopher Steele right now,
because on these big things
that got so much attention,
he hasn't been able to prove it.
-And it does seem like
some journalists
are having to go back
and reflect on the fact
that maybe they sort of
ran to the Steele dossier
a little bit faster --
-Did the people really do that?
I mean the Steele dossier --
-I guess that's my question.
-It didn't come out
during the campaign.
It came out after the campaign.
-Sure, but it did seem like,
perhaps, it made good television
to talk about
the Steele dossier.
-Right. And a lot of people did.
A lot of people went too far.
I think we at ABC
were very careful with it.
We didn't sensationalize
the claims in any way,
and we didn't report
what we couldn't verify.
But I think
some did take it too far.
-You also tell a story,
another Hulu show --
this is about someone
who stopped
a homegrown terrorist attack.
And are you surprised,
or, were you surprised
how little
people knew about this story?
-This is an amazing story.
This guy is a guy named Dan Day,
Garden City, Kansas.
Unemployed security guard,
average guy, two kids,
50-something years old.
He's kind of a Trumper,
kind of a conservative.
In 2015, he fell in
with some white supremacists.
He was horrified by what he saw,
and he became an informant
for the FBI.
Was an FBI informant
for 15 months
as these people started to plan
what would have been
the deadliest terror attack
in American history --
domestic terror attack
in American history.
They were gonna blow up
the entire Somali community
in Garden City, Kansas.
We have the tapes that are
in the documentary about that.
It didn't get
all that much attention
because the plot was foiled
three weeks
before the 2016 election.
The bombs were supposed
to go off the day after
the 2016 election,
because they didn't want
to help Hillary Clinton
and all of that.
But this story, this man
was so heroic, so selfless
and put himself and his family
at risk to stop
what would've been one of
the most horrifying things
you'd ever see.
-When you talk to someone
like that, do you get the sense
that they understand now
their own heroism?
-Every once in a while
on "Good Morning America,"
we meet people, as well, who
save people from a burning fire,
from a shark
or something like that.
To a person, they always say,
"No, I'm not a hero."
And when any person looking
at what they did would say,
"I'm not sure
I could've done that.
I'm not sure I could've
put my family at risk.
I'm not sure
I could've been hanging out
with these violent people
who were gonna do
horrible things and maybe even
put a bullet in my head,"
and he just kept on persisting
in order to stop it.
To this day, he doesn't believe
he's a hero.
He certainly is.
-I would agree with that,
as well.
Can I ask, you know,
those must be assignments
that any journalist
would look forward to,
getting to talk to a hero
like that, telling his story,
getting to talk
to Christopher Steele.
What is the worst assignment
you've ever been given?
[ Laughter ]
One of the best April Fools
jokes my wife ever played on me,
it was years and years ago
on "Good Morning America."
You know,
you often have to promote things
on this show, as well.
-Yeah.
-And I was in
the middle of the show.
And she got
the executive producers
to come into my ear and say,
"You have to fly to L.A.
right after the show
and go interview the cast
of some show that was definitely
gonna be cancelled
three weeks later."
[ Laughter ]
And she saw me
starting to turn red on set.
The entire crew was watching,
saying,
"You got to take him
out of his misery.
He's gonna blow up on air."
[ Laughter ]
They saved me.
-That was very nice.
Your "GMA" colleague,
Michael Strahan,
is gonna go to space.
-Yeah.
It's been postponed, I guess,
for a couple days.
-Really?
-It was supposed to be tomorrow.
But there's some weather issue,
but it's gonna
probably happen this weekend.
And he's ready to go.
-Would you go?
-No.
-Nor would I.
[ Laughter ]
Nor would I.
-But glad he is.
Not even tempted.
Not even a little bit.
-Not even a little bit.
Because you know what?
They got cameras up there,
so I know what it looks like.
Yeah.
-It's fine, yeah.
-They're like,
"You can't believe
what it looks like."
It's like,
"You took a picture.
I know exactly
what it looks like."
-And we're gonna broadcast it,
and all of you can watch.
Good bless you, Michael.
-God bless you.
I'm glad he's doing it.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Always a pleasure, George.
George Stephanopoulos.
"This Week
with George Stephanopoulos"
airs Sunday mornings on ABC.